money is the equivalent of energy so you
can buy energy with your cash and the
significance about that is if you're
Frugal and take care of your money and
keep a balance then you always have this
energy in your bank account energy in
which you can live however obviously if
you waste this energy then you actually
interfere with your own Survival so you
don't really want to go out and just
throw away your money and so basically I
really want to show you that this is an
important insight into the nature of our
own health and our biology and the world
recreate in this regard that our
biological system the cells rely on
energy without energy there's no life so
fundamentally you have an energy budget
that gives you life and in fact in the
body energy is in coins called ATP
molecules that represent units of energy
so in fact biologists refer to ATP as
the coin of the realm the significance
of ATP is this is that ATP molecules are
like units of gasoline like gallon of
gas that are used to fuel our biological
processes so to stay alive we have to
have all this ATP so there's an ATP
account in your body right now but the
question is how do you use this ATP and
now here's an important fact that 25 of
the total energy in your whole body is
used to operate your brain so all of a
sudden you start to recognize that the
brain uses energy at the rate of muscles
of a marathon runner so a brain and
muscle activity are pretty much the same
and so why is this important because as
you're using your brain as you're using
your thinking you are actually using
energy now why is this relevant the
answer is very simply this because the
way we've been using our thoughts are
not necessarily productive a matter of
fact sometimes our investments of our
thoughts are actually counterproductive
because our thoughts create a reality
that we then have to overcome so
basically it says that we must start to
become aware of our thoughts and why is
this important because thoughts
represent units of energy every time you
have a thought you use energy why this
becomes real relevant is if I give you a
checkbook for your bank account you
don't go down the street and just write
checks to people like oh hey you're a
nice looking guy here's 10 bucks for you
and oh here little girl go out and buy
yourself a little car here's a thousand
dollars for you and you don't give away
your money why because giving away your
money is giving away your life so
basically you become very frugal when
you have a checkbook in your hand now
what I'm trying to tell you is this you
have an energy budget in your body the
energy is what keeps you alive when you
start using energy and writing checks
where you get no return from your energy
then it's exactly the same as writing
checks out of your bank checkbook and
giving away your cash so why this
becomes important is the biology of
belief reveals how our thoughts create
our reality and if you start investing
in thoughts that are counterproductive
thoughts like fear or what am I going to
do and how am I going to escape this
problem or how's this going to go wrong
and all these other kinds of thoughts
that better negative kinds of thoughts
then realize this you are actually not
just using your energy for having these
slots but these thoughts are also what
come into your reality what you focus on
with your thoughts your brain will
manifest as reality you are what you
consistently think about whether you
think you'll win or lose you're right
it's a challenge I think a lot of us
face we are stuck in our head in our
mind telling ourselves why we can't do
something why we're not good enough why
were there we're born in the wrong
country we have the wrong skin color
we're the wrong gender we have the wrong
family we're the wrong education and we
just keep replaying these same stories
over and over and over and over and over
again and you don't win because you
believe that you can't win that's what
the great rewiring has to take place
inside all of us because that's why I
think that lack of belief is the world's
number one problem
I'm on a mission to solve the world's
number one problem people do not believe
in themselves to create amazing things I
think everybody has Michael Jordan level
genius at something that you are the
greatest in the world at something
and it's probably not what you went to
school for and it's probably not what
your parents did for a living it's
something totally different and a
challenge in being able to go and Chase
down something that's totally different
is the belief that it's possible
because when you are around people who
are not living their life
who are complaining who are negative who
may not be toxic but who are stuck
people who are stuck
the easiest thing to do is to get stuck
yourself and to have the thought
patterns that keep you stuck this is why
I create all my channels
because I need it for me because I want
to be around people who challenge me who
when I see what they're doing it forces
me to think different to think bigger to
want to do more to want to be a better
Evan Carmichael whatever that means
right to just feel like I'm I want to
grow and do more because I'm around the
people who are doing that
where if you stay stuck with the people
that you're in right now you stay stuck
in the environment that you're
participating in right now then you will
likely stay there and not grow and not
improve and not learn and not get better
now
that doesn't mean that you stop caring
it doesn't mean that you stop giving
that doesn't mean that you stop
contributing it in fact it's the
opposite
you if you're watching this video you're
on a journey you're on a growth curve
and you want to go here right you want
to climb you want to get better you're
you're you want to go over there and
there may be people who are who are even
pulling you back actively saying not to
do that don't do that you can't do that
the goal isn't even necessarily to leave
these people behind
the goal could be to come back and help
them
but how can you help them and how can
you pour even more into them well by
learning more and improving yourself
more that every time that you learn
something and you get better at
something you can come back and pour it
into other people that when you're
taking your growth curve you're stepping
you're climbing you're improving you're
getting better every step that you take
you know if you now you move to step
number four you can help others other
people get the step number three you can
reach back and help them climb up
another step
so it doesn't mean that you stop being
optimistic and positive and helpful for
the people around you that's that's your
light that's your gift that's what you
are so amazing at
but it does mean that you need to
inject newness into your environment
because your environment is crafting
your thoughts and your thoughts are
keeping you stuck
you might have these moments where you
feel bold and brave and you can do
something else but those aren't
consistent and because the boldness in
thought is not consistent the boldness
and action is not consistent and so you
stay stuck doing the same thing knowing
that you're capable of more we're not
doing the thing and this is a game for
everybody this is this is for myself
this is for you this is for the people
who are ahead of you on their growth
curve you never want to stop there's
always a new level of of self-talk and
self-belief to get you to the next thing
that's possible
so it's why I do what I do because I
need it for me I need to be around
people who inspire me every day so that
I can continue to organize for kindness
right Martin Luther King had a great
quote about organizing for kindness that
people organized for negativity to
organize uh looting and the organized
violence and their organized Wars and
their organized negativity well who's
organizing for kindness right that's
what we need to do but you need to have
the inspired environment to create the
inspired thoughts to allow the inspired
action to come out so you can organize
for kindness too
so let's break down how do you actually
start doing it how do you actually start
to change that self-talk to be a more
positive one so that you can actually
follow through on the great ideas that
you have for yourself
number one
is to be around your Heroes who are your
Heroes who have done the thing that you
love doing either the actual work itself
like they're in your industry and they
have done the thing if you know my story
you know I looked up to Bill Gates he
had a software company I had a software
company I learned from him to build my
company I haven't met him but yet but uh
his strategies saved my company and then
I also learned from someone like Oprah
Winfrey or Kanye West or people who are
not in my industry but I just like for
some reason I'm gonna go and learn from
them so who are your Heroes either in
your industry or people that you just
look up to for some reason
and force yourself to spend more time
with them
be around them more put their pictures
up on the wall behind you my favorite
entrepreneur of all time is AP giannini
who started Bank of America put their
pictures on the wall behind you
subscribe to their YouTube channels if
they have it follow them on social media
read their books listen to their
podcasts like have them be in your
environment as much as possible because
they will transport you to another world
they will help you change that self-talk
in your head because the people who have
done the thing that you want to do your
Heroes the people you look up to likely
have done it with less than what you
have right now
the the resources that you have right
now the heart that you have right now
the the mental capacity that you have
right now the tools at your disposal you
know you have the internet you've got a
lot of tools at your disposal get a lot
of Technology at your disposal that your
Heroes didn't have as much access to if
any and they went off and won
so yes it might be difficult but if they
can do it you can do it too the question
is who you're going to listen to you
know the voice that says it's too hard
I'm never going to do it or the voice
that says well they can do it I can do
it too
so you have to be around you want to
change that self-talk you have to be
around your mentors Your Heroes because
they will pull you to a different place
set number two is to create a calendar
that has your habits in there your goals
that you've set for yourself needs to be
reflected in the habits because goals
don't accomplish themselves goals will
happen when you put time on your
calendar to go and make it happen I'm
making this video because it's in my
calendar this block of time right now to
go make videos right what do you need to
put in your calendar so that it's not
just a hope a dream a goal but it
actually becomes something that's in
reality and then to start to teach
yourself that you do the things that are
in your own calendar you want to start
to change yourself belief yourself talk
your that voice inside your head you
have to teach yourself that you follow
through on the things that you say
you're gonna do have fewer goals have
fewer things that you write down in your
calendar
but when they're in there they get done
because here's what happens every time
you set a goal every time you put
something in your calendar and you don't
do it you're training yourself that the
next time you put something in your
calendar that's not going to get done
too you're losing credibility with
yourself not even somebody else saying
you can't do it it's you your own voice
saying you can't do it because you
haven't done the last thing that you
said you were going to do or the thing
before that
so the rate is start to rewire that is
to when you put something in your
calendar it's going to get done to even
lower the barrier lower the standard for
what has to get done for you to get the
check mark that you accomplished this
thing that when it gets put in your
calendar you are going to be the person
who actually follows through that starts
to shift identity
that starts to help you believe more in
yourself that the next thing that you
add in your calendar you're also going
to get done
so how do we start to change that
self-talk right that criticism or or
compassionate voice in our head how do
we how do we shift towards belief one be
around our mentors and our heroes the
people who Inspire us to do it to create
a calendar that reflects our goals our
actions have to map to our Ambitions
right has to be in your calendar and
teach yourself that you do the things
that are in your calendar and step
number three would be to collect good
people
I'm a huge fan of collecting good people
if you believe like I believe that your
environment is keeping you stuck and
keeping you where you are okay a shift
can be to be around your Heroes but you
never you may never meet them
good people when you're around the right
people
who fill you up as opposed to you
filling others up all the time it
changes everything you're a giver you're
caring you've got a big heart it's why
you're part of this community I love you
for that and keep going keep doing it
don't stop pointing to others
but who's pointing to you
when you walk away from a conversation
how often do you feel better about
yourself how often you have more energy
as opposed to well that was draining to
me you need to start to inject the
people who make you feel better who give
you more energy
and you may know some of them they may
not be the closest of friends to you yet
but whenever you meet somebody if it's
at an event or a conference or group or
in the comments section or on a Discord
and they just make you feel better
fight to try to find a way to spend more
time with them the way I'll often do it
is through businesses I end up setting
companies with them because I love them
so much it's a way to spend more time
with them
but it can be awkward at the beginning
like you don't know what you're gonna do
but you'll be the person to reach out to
say hey I'd love to have a coffee with
you next week or maybe we can schedule a
a monthly Mastermind with us and maybe a
couple other people like you reach out
to find a way to collect good people and
fight to spend more time with them
because when you're around actual humans
who are in front of you who make you
feel better about yourself and give you
the energy that you're pouring in other
people
it gives you more hope more momentum and
increases the chance of you actually
following through so get into the
practice of collecting good people
lack of belief is the single biggest
problem in the world you
have Michael Jordan level genie says
something you are the greatest in the
world at something
it's just your belief my belief too and
the ability to actually go and Chase it
down that will make the difference
between the life that you have right now
and the life that you know you're
capable of living let's solve that
together
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
maybe we should start focusing on what
we want and not focusing on on what
we're afraid of and that's where the
bigger problem comes from at this moment
and recognizing this has been brought up
before we're birthing a new civilization
and recognize this birth is always
associated with some pain a little blood
uh as the process unfolds and so when we
look at the world and we say it's
struggling right now I say yeah this is
a birthing pain that we're experiencing
and you have a choice you could focus on
the pain
where you can focus on the baby that's
coming here and think about it know how
much of a woman is screaming the moment
before the baby comes out uh the moment
the baby's out there's no more pain
anymore it's gone because the Love Has
covered everything you know and this is
what we're at now this is where we are
we are creating something new let's not
focus on on the Pain part because it's
the birth that is the most amazing
experiencing uh experience that is
coming to this planet right now
all of us are on the threshold of seeing
a new civilization this is an amazing
time
in human civilization we're here to
observe an evolutionary event unfolding
immediately in front of your eyes but
we're more than observers we're
participants
and that's what this whole uplift
program is all about each one of us is
contributing a vibration a Consciousness
a thought
and building something so beautiful
that heaven on Earth is actually a way
of life money is the equivalent of
energy so you can buy energy with your
cash and the significance about that is
if you're Frugal and take care of your
money and keep a balance then you always
have this energy in your bank account
energy in which you can live however
obviously if you waste this energy then
you actually interfere with your own
Survival so you don't really want to go
out and just throw away your money and
so basically I really want to show you
that this is an important insight into
the nature of our own health and our
biology in the world recreate in this
regard that our biological system the
cells rely on energy without energy
there's no life so fundamentally you
have an energy budget that gives you
life and in fact in the body energy is
in coins called ATP molecules that
represent units of energy so in fact
biologists refer to ATP as the coin of
the realm the significance of ATP is
this is that 8 TP molecules are like
units of gasoline like gallon of gas
that are used to fuel our biological
processes so to stay alive we have to
have all this ATP so there's an ATP
account in your body right now but the
question is how do you use this ATP and
now here's an important fact that 25 of
the total energy in your whole body is
used to operate your brain so all of a
sudden you start to recognize that the
brain uses energy at the rate of muscles
of a marathon runner so a brain and
muscle activity are pretty much the same
and so why is this important because as
you're using your brain as you're using
your thinking you are actually using
energy now why is this relevant the
answer is very simply this because the
way we've been using our thoughts are
not necessarily productive a matter of
fact sometimes our investments of our
thoughts are actually counterproductive
because our thoughts create a reality
that we then have to overcome so
basically it says that we must start to
become aware of our thoughts and why is
this important because thoughts
represent units of energy every time you
have a thought you use energy why this
becomes relevant is if I give you a
checkbook for your bank account you
don't go down the street and just write
checks to people like oh hey you're a
nice looking guy here's 10 bucks for you
and oh here little girl go out and buy
yourself a little car here's a thousand
dollars for you and you don't give away
your money why because giving away your
money is giving away your life so
basically you become very frugal when
you have a checkbook in your hand now
what I'm trying to tell you is this you
have an energy budget in your body the
energy is what keeps you alive when you
start using energy and writing checks
where you get no return from your energy
then it's exactly the same as writing
checks out of your bank checkbook and
giving away your cash so why this
becomes important is the biology of
belief reveals how our thoughts create
our reality and if you start start
investing in thoughts that are
counterproductive thoughts like fear or
what am I going to do and how am I going
to escape this problem or how is this
going to go wrong and all these other
kinds of thoughts that are negative
kinds of thoughts then realize this you
are actually not just using your energy
for having these thoughts but these
thoughts are also what come into your
reality what you focus on with your
thoughts your brain will manifest as
reality and in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material Physical Realm was
a total illusion that everything is
energy the whole thing there is no
matter in this world and to summarize
what the meaning was of famous
physicists in 1930 by the name of Sir
James jeans said we have been led to
believe that the universe is a great
machine when in fact fact it is more a
great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that Consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal Nature which is
like a a scientific mainstream Journal
was an article by a Quantum physicist at
Johns Hopkins University by the name of
Richard con Henry and his article was
entitled the mental universe I I know
the last two lines in the article
because they were like so powerful and
here's what the conclusion of the
article was
the universe is immaterial it's mental
and spiritual live and enjoy and this is
so exciting because science is coming
out saying it mental and spiritual is
like oh my God but that's the quantum
physics part and the reality about it
why is that so important as uh Assad
Vijaya just mentioned it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now I say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize I'm having a
thought well then the truth is simple as
Richard con Henry said you are creating
this world with your mental activity and
your spirituality combined and then all
of a sudden it says well then if I'm
creating the world then my original
belief that when things didn't go right
I was a victim the universe wasn't
supporting me you know it's like oh I
try so hard and the universe is not
giving me things it turns 180 degrees
around and it basically says this
we are creating this world
and then I say your mind is creating
this world I was looking for
relationships I kept failing at them
okay I end up in the Caribbean teaching
at a medical school
the universe throws this into my lap the
perfect pickup line in the whole world
is sort of like hey if you're not doing
anything you want to come and stay in my
villa in the Caribbean and hang out I
have a villa on the beach and I got my
own place and uh blah blah blah and I
still wasn't able to find anybody but I
kept looking because I said I need a
relationship I need a relationship so I
meet this woman who comes off of some
yacht and she's you know I've got a
future that's like she'll do what she
wants and I thought well if you're not
doing anything why don't you uh you want
to come and stay with me and my Villa on
this beautiful Island
he looked at me and she looked at me and
then she said I can't be with you and I
sort of like stop for a moment and she
looked at me and she says you're too
needy
it was it hit me I said oh my God what
am I looking for a relationship why
because you're not happy so if you're
looking for a relationship because
you're not happy then you're depending
on that relationship to make you happy
so that's not a nice relationship it's
codependency if I give you this place to
stay you will make me happy that's a
trade you know it's like yes and after
she said that I was stunned for a moment
I can't be with you you're too needy she
said and I was stuck and then all of a
sudden I said Thank you thank you very
much it was sort of a slap in the face
right the blessing in disguise right it
totally was it was like wake up and I
walked away from that and I looked at my
life and said you got this most amazing
job you teach a couple days a week you
live in the Caribbean you've got a villa
you got money in your pocket because you
get paid and there's nothing to buy in
the Caribbean anyways I got I say you're
healthy you got money you got a great
place to live you have the most
wonderful job I go you can't be happy
with that that's what I said to myself
I said how can I you know I'm looking
for this person to make me happy I said
oh no first I make me happy yeah and
then when I make me happy
that changed and it did what happened is
I stopped bitching and started to enjoy
look don't you love where you live yeah
I love where I live do you love Lucia oh
I love the sea you like it oh I love my
job and all of a sudden I started
focusing on hey these are things I love
and guess what
I didn't need anybody
that's when you created abundance and
that's when people became attracted to
you right 100 because once I didn't need
them I wasn't like yeah come here I was
like yes I don't care how it works and
they showed up they showed up because I
did not need that was the word because
need puts pressure on that other person
that they have to provide and then they
didn't have to provide it was like hey
let me hang out with you I don't have to
provide anything I could just be me I go
yeah you be you I'd be me we have a
great time
and that was the beginning of
reprogramming a need for a relationship
until I was happy with myself and until
that happened once I was happy with
myself and I didn't need a relationship
you should have seen how many
opportunities showed up that were never
there in my life before because the need
part pushed them away I was cloning stem
cells back in 1967. 40 years ago and the
significant against was while I was
doing this research I was also teaching
medical students so I was teaching
medical students the foundation of how
cells work the conventional story out of
the textbook genes control life what we
call the genetic determinism the belief
that genes control your traits Behavior
your physical characteristics Etc and
what my research revealed when I was
studying the stem cells was this very
profound I put one stem cell in a Petri
dish all by itself and it would divide
every 10 to 12 hours so it'd be 2 4 8 16
cells 32 cells after about two weeks I
have thousands of cells in the petri
dish but what was unique they were all
genetically identical but then I did the
experiment the experiment was to take
some cells out of the dish and put them
into a separate dish with a different
environment okay and so the environment
is a culture medium but the culture
medium to cells is like the world that
we live in it's got the air the water
the food all the things in it so I take
the cells out of my stem cell dish put
them in a separate dish with a different
environment and the cells form muscle
but then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells in it
took some cells out put them in a
different environment and they form bone
and then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells and put
them in a third petri dish with a
different environment and they form fat
cells and there I was confronted with
this reality all the cells are
genetically identical but they had
different fade fat muscle bone I say
simple question what controls the fate
of cells and the answer is the
environment it was the only thing that
was different because they were all
genetically identical so I started to
really say oh my goodness here I am
teaching genes control life to the
medical students and yet the cells were
revealing to me that hey they all had
the same genes but it was environment
that I put them in and so the
environment controlled their life and a
very simple experiment that is very
profound for us today is if I took my
dish with plastic petri dish with cells
in it and moved it from a healthy
environment to a less and healthy
environment the cells get sick and if I
were a doctor of cells I you might say
well what kind of drugs would you give
these cells and it turns out no you
don't give the cells any drugs you just
take the dish from the bad environment
put it back into a good environment and
the cells will innately naturally come
back to health again the science that
says there are two minds that are
operating at the same time one is called
the conscious mind or one is called the
subconscious mind I say What's the
difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are in that conscious mind and
perceiving the world I say what about
the subconscious mind it's not a
creative mind the subconscious mind is
habits things that you've learned and
you experienced in your life and they
become habits so the subconscious mind
is not thinking creating a subconscious
mind push the button play the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh I wish I had this and
I desire that and these are the things I
want and then you go out and start the
day and then guess what
95 of the day you are not operating from
the conscious mind science is recognize
95 of the day because we are thinking 95
percent of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
I go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people your mother your father
your siblings and your community so what
is the difference you wake up with a
wish and a desire of what you want
and then the rest of the day you play
the programs that you got from other
people that don't answer your wishes and
don't support your desires and all you
see is the consequence of it and go oh
my God why is it not working the answer
is because you don't see because
remember the name is subconscious below
conscious so when that behavior is
playing psychologists will tell us 70
percent or more of the programs in the
subconscious are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage all the
desires and wishes you you have and then
to conclude that
what if you just didn't default to the
subconscious what if you just stayed in
the conscious mind that's called being
Mindful and why is it relevant because
when you stay conscious keep your mind
present you are the creator of your life
and when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion you're really
running your life with your programs
acquired from other people well how do
you change the subconscious mind say how
did it learn in the first place
I say what was the first one I say Theta
seven years brain was functioning lower
vibration than Consciousness you have to
slow down the brain to a much slower
vibration then it goes into the
subconscious mind that's why um
hypnotherapists in the old days they had
a watch and they would swing it back and
forth so the watch would swing and they
would tell the person you're getting
sleepy you're getting tired and the
reason they say that is because that
shuts down the conscious vibration and
the next vibration is Theta which is
hypnosis so to get you into hypnosis
first I have to get your conscious brain
to stop and then in hypnosis State Theta
the vibration Theta then whatever is
coming from the outside is not going
into my conscious mind whatever I see on
the outside is going into my
subconscious program so if you want to
change the subconscious you have to talk
to the subconscious they go how do you
do that well number one hypnosis and I
go oh what I need to see the
hypnotherapist I go no this is the cool
part I say why I said we have different
vibrations the lowest vibration is Delta
is sleep the next higher vibration is
Theta hypnosis imagination the next
higher vibration is Alpha calm
Consciousness and the next higher
vibration is called beta which is like
School room like what we're doing here
Consciousness okay I go so why is it rub
I said when you're asleep you're at the
lowest and when you start to wake up you
go up first to Theta and that's like in
the morning where you're half awake and
half asleep and and then I say but then
when you're awake you're an alpha now
you're in Consciousness and then when
you go to work you're in beta which is
like the work in Consciousness but when
you come home it reverses so I come home
from work I'm in beta but I relax oh the
Consciousness vibration slows down the
alpha and here's the fact the moment
that the vibrations get a little lower
than Alpha Consciousness is now shut off
for the night you're sleeping yeah but
there's a period of time after Alpha
shuts off before it reaches Delta the
lowest one there's a period of time of
theta I go why is it relevant I said you
put earphones on
and the moment and you play a program of
what of what you want a self-help
program of have a mega relationship be
healthy do a job whatever you get the
program self-help program I say you put
it on on a CD player let's say and you
put the earphones on and while you're
still awake just before you go to sleep
you can hear what's going on but the
moment you fall asleep conscious mind
shut off but guess what Theta is on the
work is getting done right right you're
getting a self-hypnosis with the
earphone so whatever the you didn't hear
it you were sleeping the subconscious
mind was hearing it and when you repeat
that that's how you put a new program in
so that's number one self-hypnosis I had
tenure I had tenure at the University I
walked out of the university and said
look I I can't keep my integrity and at
the same time teach something I know was
patently wrong so I walked out because I
saw that teaching the belief that genes
control life was very very very
Incorrect and it's very interesting
because I did that in 1970 now that's
like 30 40 years ago when we look at our
lives and I tell you that 95 of your
life is coming from the subconscious
program
this is not it's new on a scientific
awareness of how this mechanism works
but what's interesting is for 400 years
the knowledge that you could program
somebody and control their lives has
been available it was the Jesuits who
400 years ago said give me a child until
it's seven and I will show you the man
most people didn't understand what they
were saying and what it is is the first
seven years which we now know
biologically and scientifically is the
program period they knew that 400 years
ago and they said if I can get that
program in the first seven years that
program will determine the life of that
individual I'll show you the man because
they will represent the program
now the really important part is since
every one of us has been programmed
the the big issue is so what were those
programs because if I ask you so what
what program did you get when you were
one year old I have no idea I wasn't
really there in fact you were actually
being programmed even before you were
born the last trimester of pregnancy you
were being programmed and I go well this
is really a critical issue because the
first thing I'm telling you is your life
is 95 program uh and most of that is is
really disempowering and of course the
first thing I would think is and what
are those programs so I could deal with
them so I want to make something very
easy for you so you don't have to go and
review your whole life and try to figure
out what the programs are save you a lot
of time
the fact is this you are playing the
program 95 of the day meaning your life
is a printout of your program so you
don't have to go back in time to review
that would just actually irritate the
system more because every time you
review those things that unsettled you
when when you were younger it just
reinforces that same pain that you had
earlier so going back uh and finding out
who did what to who uh is more than just
a waste of time it actually will set you
back a matter of fact there's an an old
phrase that people have heard and it
says Don't Kill the Messenger over the
message
what that means is this don't go back
and blame all the people that did this
and that and that and that that's
irrelevant who they are is irrelevant
what's relevant is what program did you
walk away with not who did the event but
what you learned so now I said okay I've
been programmed and I have no idea what
the program and I said then look at your
life and here's the simple resolution
everything in your life that you like
and it comes to you is because you have
a program to support that that's
wonderful that means that's great it's
going to come to you because that
program is bringing it to you but in
contrast this is the one that's
important
anything you work hard to accomplish
anything you struggle over to make it
happen anything you put a lot of effort
in I want this I'm going to work like
crazy I'm gonna get this my first
question is why are you working so hard
and the answer is very simple
anything you're struggling to try to
accomplish whether it's health or love
relationships whatever it is if you're
struggling it represents a simple fact
your subconscious programming doesn't
support that conclusion
so the fact is what are my programs look
at your struggle and wherever you're
struggling the struggle is not because
the universe won't provide for you the
struggle is an internal job the struggle
is you're trying to overcome previous
programming that prevents you to go to
that destination so the wonderful part
about this understanding is you don't
have to to review your life you can look
right now at this one moment just look
in your head and say what are the things
that I keep trying to get and they they
seem to be elusive I can't get them
they're always Out Of Reach I say their
their universe is not holding back
it's your own invisible subconscious
behavior when you're putting in a wish
and a desire put it in as if you already
have it
I am healthy I am a good relationship
person I you know I have a great job
what's that I say it's like I already
have it and yet most people don't have
it so they'll say I want a great job I
want a great relationship I want to be
healthy and I go make a recording of
those words we just said that I want to
be healthy today right now Tuesday we're
going to make a recording I say now come
back in one year and let's push the
button on that recording and we come
back a year later and it says I want to
be healthy I go it's a whole year and
you still want to be honest I still
don't have it right you didn't say I am
healthy while you're emphasizing I have
a desire to be healthy I want to be
healthy I have a desire to be health and
I go
you can have that desire the rest of
your life you're not going to get
healthy you want to be healthy you say I
am healthy but then you're looking to
say yeah but in reality I'm sick and I
go no no the function of the mind is to
take the program and turn it into
reality so if I am sick but I put a
program in I am healthy the Mind looks
you know like well wait a second the
program is I am healthy but the body is
not healthy so what's the function of
the Mind create Health in the body it
doesn't change the program it changes
the body and so the idea is this every
time we put a program in it has to be as
if you already have it and it's by the
fact you could be dying of cancer I go I
am healthy it sounds kind of weird and I
go don't worry about it just put it on I
am healthy because once it is a program
the function of the mind is to manifest
it as reality
that's the part and so my little caveat
you brought it up I'm emphasizing it and
that was simply this that whatever
you're downloading you have to say it as
if you already have it because if you
put a future tense on it I will I want I
say if you record that that means you
will always will you know want to have
it you know I will do this you won't get
there so I just want to bring that in
because if we're making a program then
you must make sure it says as if you
already have it in spite of the fact you
don't yo ho ho and about love from the
dead man's on the la la la la la la la
oh wow what a glorious day to be sailing
on the sea
I think I should be checking my bearings
at this point
North by Northwest that's that's right
Hank told me take a left at the island
then follow North by Northwest until I
go towards the sunset but it should be
here somewhere Long Island should be
somewhere about
it's not here
I think I better check my calculations
again
so I left Port Moresby at 12 and going
at eight knots by 12 35 we should have
been over here to the left at the island
and then we followed the tangent of the
cosine of 381 for eight minutes to the
right and then we should be approaching
toward Kong Island
[Music]
uh uh
uh oh
I'm lost at sea
what should I do now
I knew I should have trusted my feelings
when Hank gave me directions it just
didn't even feel right and in today's
world we're told don't go by the
feelings if I did I would have probably
been better off at this moment so when
we recognize we have to make a decision
we can do it in two fundamental ways
first do an assessment an analysis of
step by step what does this decision
mean and why should I choose it but when
you get to the end before you absolutely
take that information and make a
decision based on that
ask your heart and the reason why is
this the heart doesn't care about the
individual steps in the decision the
heart only looks at the conclusion
either you get more energy from this
decision a good vibe a feeling that this
is right or the heart will give you a
feeling of bad vibes less energy a
feeling that maybe this isn't the right
answer so the significance is really
profound because the heart just reads
energy and higher energy is more life
less energy is less life so in making a
decision yes it's acceptable to do the
analysis but before you come to that
final decision please check in with your
heart feel the feelings if the feelings
are good that means go toward that
direction but if you feel questioned
about it you feel weaker about it
doesn't just feel right the heart is
telling you right off that that energy
is not good for you and you should use
some other decision oh wow that's so
wonderful what a wonderful way to make a
decision based on these feelings and
they can help us find the direction that
we need to go in and lead us to a better
life
[Music]
uh-oh
I guess that's not really working for me
at this moment
whoops
oh well
computer and simulation
[Music]
Scotty how many times have I told you
not to leave me often see you know I
can't swim
meet me at the bridge you have some
explaining to do if you want another
Amazing Joe dispenza video check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you